المترجم: Ahmed Abdelghany
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
السلام عليكم
وعليكم السلام
أنا إلياس العامري
من مدينة تعز
عمري عشر سنوات
أحكي لكم قصة حدثت لي
وتحدث لجميع أطفال اليمن
في العام 2015
قبل ثلاث سنوات من الآن
كنت ألعب في الحارة
بجانب البيت أنا وأصحابي
بفتاتير (كرات زجاجية)
فجأة! حدث انفجار شديد
الكل خاف وهرب لبيته
وأنا جريت إلى البيت
وحين وصلت الدرج
انفجر صاروخ ثان
أفلت من الدرجة
وقمت بصعوبة
وواصلت الجري إلى البيت
أرى الكل يصرخون مرعوبين
وجدي كان يشهد ويكبر
وبعد ذلك جاء صاروخ ثالث ورابع
وتكسرت نوافذ البيت
وانتزعت الأبواب من مكانها
وامتلأ البيت بالغبار
كانت ليلة مخيفة
مليئة بالقذائف والانفجارات
وفي الصباح
خرجنا إلى خارج تعز
بدون أمي
لأنها كانت جالسة في البيت مع جدي
وكان مريضَا
بعد أسبوعين
رجعنا إلى البيت
ولكن ما زالت الانفجارات
تدك البيت والحارة
بعد فترة
قصفوا الحارة بالمدافع
نزحنا إلى القرية
جلست فيها أربعة أشهر
ولم أدخل المدرسة
لأن مستوى التدريس كان منخفضًا
ولم يلب طلبي حينها
كان أهل القرية كلهم يحبون
القات والسلاح
تعلمت في تلك الفترة
مضغ القات وحمل السلاح
تخيلوا أني كنت أحمل سلاحا
أما الآن
سلاحي هو العلم
والغيتار
(عزف على الجيتار)
شكرًا
خافت أمي على مستقبلي وتفكيري
فقالت: "ننزح إلى صنعاء"
أنا لم أكن أرغب بالنزوح إلى صنعاء
لأنني متعود على أصحابي الذين أعيش معهم
وعلى أهلي
لكن نزحنا إلى صنعاء
وأول ما وصلنا البيت
كنا خائفين
البيت ظلام
ولم يكن لي أصحاب
كي ألعب معهم
بعد فترة
وجدنا مدرسة جنبنا قريبة
دخلت فيها
وحصلت على تكريم من مدير المدرسة
وإلى الآن أحصل على تكريم من مدير المدرسة
وفي ذات مساء
أخذتني أمي إلى معرض الآلات الموسيقية
قالت لي: "اختر آلة
تكون صديقة لك"
اخترت الغيتار
أحسست أنه الأقرب لقلبي
وبدأت أنزل مقاطع من الإنترنت
وأعلم نفسي
والاّن أنا أدرس موسيقى
لأطور من مهاراتي بالعزف
رغم صغر سني
إلا أنني اكتشفت أن الحرب
أبشع ما في هذه الحياة
وأنها تأخذ كل جميل
فقد أخذت مني أخي أسامة
الذي ستكون ذكرى رحيله غدًا
29 نوفمبر
أوقفوا الحرب!
لنعيش بسلام كبقية أطفال العالم
لنعزف الموسيقى
وننشر الحياة والحب والسلام
(تصفيق)
(عزف على الجيتار)
شكرًا